just days after announcing his
Republican Presidential candidacy with a
glitchy and humiliating Twitter spaces
event Ron DeSantis has now signed a bill
into state law protecting private
companies that orchestrate space flights
from liability lawsuits if a crew member
were to get injured or die as a result
of an accident it just so happens that
that Shields Elon musk's SpaceX from
lawsuits musk getting cozy with DeSantis
orchestrating that failed campaign
launch on Twitter and saying that he's
the type of guy we need doing this that
and the other thing DeSantis also
praising musk really throwing bouquets
at each other and just 24 hours after
appearing on Twitter spaces with musk
DeSantis signs this bill into law that
would Shield SpaceX and other private
space companies admittedly from any kind
of negligence lawsuit